[Music]
we are going to superimpose the
structure of myoglobin on hemoglobin to
try and see how closely related or how
similar the structures of these two
proteins are
in this viewer page i can just say
download structures
uh for hh
and one nvo
apply your 4hhb is
um these darker colored
uh chains and this light green chain is
one mbo so i'm going to select
the chain
um i'm going to select chain
d
so if i just click anywhere it is
selected see it selected this whole
chain it's highlighted in green
and i'm going to now select the
myoglobin
there is only one chain in myoglobin so
i can just click on this
because the selection mode is chain i
click on anywhere in this chain the
whole chain gets selected so now right
now
two chains are selected
and that's showing up here in the
structure as in two structures two
chains selected
i'm gonna say superposition
by chain
these are the two chains i have selected
and i say super pose
and notice the green chain that was
sitting here got moved if i remove
selection so the light green chain is
sitting on top of this magenta chain
and the root mean square deviation
of the c alphas in these two chains is
1.87
so if you look at it quickly you can see
that the myoglobin and hemoglobin chains
are
the overall structure is very similar
though there are subtle differences and
you know that's a whole other discussion
what the tool can do for you is it can
take two different structures chains
that you specify and it can superimpose
them this may be a handy thing when
you're looking at proteins that are
either evolutionarily related or
proteins that are uh you know mutated
and you want to see how the structure
was similar or different
[Music]
you